so what do we do here how is this
different from Facebook oh well it's not
Facebook is it MySpace no it's not my
thing
can I send tweets through ello no no
it's it's separate it's not Twitter I
see a picture of my dog we've already
seen it yeah it's on your Facebook and
your Instagram and your Twitter and your
snapchat we promise never to sell your
personal information or show you ads how
are you gonna make money so we are gonna
charge you for additional features I
don't want that can I post videos oh no
not yet
can I send private messages no we don't
have a mobile app yet okay what can I do
on this godforsaken website not much
isn't it great I'm single can I post
nude photos it's not a dating app does
it cost me money to put on nude photos
or do I pay for other people let's stop
talking about nude photo do you want to
see a picture of my dog can i link my
facebook profile to it can I pin things
you guys it's its own it's a different
thing all right I'm just gonna say it
this place sucks yeah there's nothing to
do here do we even need another social
network it's easy for you to say we're
still trying to get in does anybody have
an invite
I know a guy can I like other people's
post not yet instead give them this loaf
of bread why apparently it's a thing in
Germany I like your picture of your dog
what the [ __ ] is this